.
>> Jesse: 2008 WAS A YEAR TO
REMEMBER.
PEOPLE'S LIFE SAVINGS EVAPOR
RATE OFFED, THEIR JOBS GONE.
THEIR HOMES FORECLOSED ON.
IT WAS ALL THANKS TO WALL STREET
WITH THE HELP OF FAN WERE AND
FREDDY AND BUFFOONS LIKE BARNEY
FRANK DOING OVERSIGHT.
BANKS LOADED ONE RISKY MORTGAGE
PRODUCTS THAT BLEW THE ECONOMY.
INSTEAD OF SLAPPING HANDCUFFS ON
BAD BANKERS, WASHINGTON SAID
WALL STREET WAS TOO BIG TO FAIL
AND EXECUTIVES GOT THEIR GOLDEN
PARACHUTES WHILE MAIN STREET GOT
NOTHING.
>> THIS IS AMERICA.
HOW MANY OF YOU PEOPLE WANT TO
PAY FOR YOUR NEIGHBOR'S MORTGAGE
THAT HAS AN EXTRA BATHROOM AND
CAN'T PAY THEIR BILLS?
RAISE THEIR HAND?
HOW ABOUT WE ALL.
[CROWD BOOS]
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA, ARE YOU
LISTENING?
>> Jesse: WALL STREET BET ON
BARACK OBAMA AND THAT IS STILL
PAYING OFF.
UNDER BARACK OBAMA WALL STREET
AND WASHINGTON FELL IN LOVE AND
NEVER LOOKED BACK.
BIG BANKS BAILED OUT BY
DEMOCRATS AND THEN THE BIG BANKS
DONATE TO DEMOCRATS.
AND THEN DEMOCRATS LEAVE THE BIG
BANKS ALONE.
WASHINGTON HIRES GUYS FROM WALL
STREET AND THEN WALL STREET
HIRES GUYS FROM WASHINGTON.
AND THEY ALL SCRATCH EACH
OTHER'S BACK.
HOWEVER, A DECADE LATER.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN TRYING TO HIDE
IT.
>> I WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW
RAISE YOUR HAND SHE HAD BEEN MY
TEAM MEMBER FOR A COUPLE TIMES
NOW ON MONDAY SHE BECOMES A BANK
OF AMERICA TEAM MEMBER ABOUT
WHICH SHE IS VERY, VERY EXCITED.
I HOPE YOU WILL TAKE GOOD CARE
OF HER AND KNOW THE TALENT SHE
HAS SHOWN ALREADY IN OUR OFFICE
I'M SURE SHE WILL DO THE SAME AT
BANK OF AMERICA.
>> WE WILL DO THAT AND HER
FATHER ALREADY WORKS FOR US.
>> YOU SHOULD HAVE CALLED US.
>> Jesse: SOME THINGS WILL NEVER
CHANGE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE ALWAYS BALTD OUT
THEIR BIGGEST BACKERS FOR YEARS.
IF YOU DONATED JUST ENOUGH MONEY
TO DEMOCRATS, YOU COULD DO JUST
ABOUT ANYTHING.
HARVEY WEINSTEIN GOT AWAY WITH
RAPING WOMEN FOR YEARS.
JEFFREY EPSTEIN WAS FLYING
MINORS TO PEDOPHILE ISLAND, EVEN
BILL CLINTON RODE ON HIS JETS.
WE ARE SEEING THE SAME THING
PLAY OUT WITH THIS CRYPTO MEGA
DONOR SAM BANKMAN-FRIED WHO JUST
ROBBED INVESTORS IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT.
A MILLION PEOPLE WOKE UP, THEIR
LIFE SAVINGS VANISHED.
OVER $2 BILLION OF FTX'S
CLIENT'S MONEY POOF.
IS MINI MADOFF BEHIND BARS?
NO, IS HE CHILLING IN THE
BAHAMAS.
BIDEN IS NOT EVEN TRYING TO
EXTRADITE HIM.
WHY WOULD HE?
HE GAVE JOE $10 MILLION IN 2020
AND SPENT OVER 40 MILLION MORE
ON DEMOCRATS IN THE MIDTERMS.
THIS PONZI SCHEMER'S DIRTY MONEY
BOUGHT DEMOCRATS DISSENT.
HE IS THEIR SECOND LARGEST DONOR
JUST BEHIND SOROS.
THIS MINI MADOFF CRYPTO KING
THROWN IN OUR FACE, TOO.
STILL, RIGHT NOW, TRYING TO
RAISE MONEY.
HE JUST LOST $32 BILLION AND HE
IS ASKING FOR MORE.
AND NOT ONLY THAT THE GUY SLEPT
WITH HIS WHOLE STAFF.
HE WAS IN A POLYMEROUS
RELATIONSHIP WITH 10 OF HIS TOP
EXECUTIVES IN PENT HOUSE OFFICE
IN BAHAMAS WHICH HAPPENS TO BE
NOTORIOUS -- HOW COME THIS GUY
HASN'T BEEN ME TOOD.
CEOS CAN GOD ARE FLIRTING.
THIS GUY HAS SEX WITH HIS AT THE
OFFICE.
WHERE IS GLORIA ALLRED?
WHERE IS ANY OF THESE DEMOCRATS?
HOW CAN YOU HAVE OFFICE ORGIES
IN CORPORATE AMERICA AND RAID
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM CLIENTS
AT THE SAME TIME AND NOT GET
ARRESTED?
$2 BILLIONS IS GONE BECAUSE OF A
GUY WHO MAKES LES MOONVES LOOK
LIKE A CHOIR BOY AND THE HEAD OF
THE CONGRESSIONAL FINANCE
COMMITTEE DEMOCRAT MAXINE WATERS
NO, RELATION, JUST DOESN'T SEEM
VERY INTERESTED.
>> DO YOU THINK SOME LAWMAKERS
THAT GOT DONATIONS FROM FTFX'S
FOUNDER SHOULD GIVE MONEY BACK.
>> WELL, I DON'T WANT TO GET
INTO THAT.
>> Jesse: OH, SO THE BIGGEST
FINANCIAL FRAUD CASE IN AMERICAN
HISTORY, BIGGER THAN MADOFF,
BIGGER THAN ENRON HAD SWAYED AN
ELECTION WITH A SIDE OF ME TOO.
MAXINE DOESN'T WANT TO GET INTO
THAT?
I WONDER WHY.
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS WOULD HAVE TO
GIVE THE MONEY BACK.
AND THEY WON'T.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE THE
SENATE BACK, SO WHY WOULD THEY
GIVE BACK THE MONEY?
MINI MADOFF NOT WORRIED ONE BIT.
HE IS TELLING THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" HE HAS JUST BEEN HANGING
OUT AND PLAYING VIDEO GAMES THIS
WEEK.
IT'S ONLY $2 BILLION MISSING.
NO BIG DEAL.
MINI MADOFF DOESN'T CARE HOW BAD
IT MAKES HIM LOOK AS LONG AS IT
MAKES THE DEMOCRATS RICH.
HE HAS ALWAYS MADE THAT CLEAR.
>> WHAT ABOUT YOUR OWN LEGACY,
SAM?
WHAT IMPACT WOULD YOU WANT TO
LEAVE ON THE WORLD LONG TERM?
>> I DON'T GIVE A [BLEEP] ABOUT
MY LEGACY.
I CARE ABOUT THE IMPACT THAT I
HAVE.
IT'S NOT, LIKE, THE THING THAT I
TRY TO REMIND MYSELF IS LIKE, AT
THE END OF THE DAY, WHAT MATTERS
IS THE IMPACT I HAVE NOT WHETHER
ANYONE KNOWS ABOUT THAT IMPACT.
>> Jesse: OKAY.
MINI MADOFF KNOWS NO ONE IS
TOUCHING HIM.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
REGULATORS, THEY ARE ALL ON HIS
SIDE.
WHO IS THE HEAD OF THE SCC?
OTHER, GARY QUINCY LER.
GARY WAS JUST HAVING LUNCH WITH
MINI MADOFF BEFORE HE STOLE HIS
CASH.
GARY'S OLD CANCER WAS THE FATHER
OF MINI MADOFF OFFICE
GIRLFRIEND.
WHEN HE WAS ASKED ABOUT IT HE
SQUIRMED.
>> SAM BANKMAN-FRIED, IT APPEARS
FROM YOUR CALENDAR ON MARCH 29TH
2022 CAME IN AND ACTUALLY MET
WITH YOU.
DID YOU FEEL LIKE YOU WERE HOOD
WINKED?
>> I THINK WE HAVE BEEN CLEAR IN
THESE MEETINGS AND YOU CAN LOOK
AT MY CALENDAR IS PUBLIC MANY
MEETINGS WITH FOLKS IN THIS
INDUSTRY.
>> Jesse: WHAT WAS THE FRIEND OF
THE REGULATIONS DOING HELPING A
SCAM ARTIST?
TRYING TO GAME THE SYSTEM
TOGETHER.
FIND LOOPHOLES TO GIVE MINI
MADOFF MORE WIGGLE ROOM AND IT
WAS NEVER A SECRET.
>> OPTIMIST OVER THE NEXT YEAR
OR TWO WE WILL SEE STEPS FORWARD
IN THE GLOBAL REGULATORY AND
U.S. MARKET FOR CRYPTO CURRENCY.
IT'S BEEN A TOUGH STRUGGLE BACK
AND FORTH FOR A WHILE BUT I
THINK THERE IS A LEGACY INTO THE
TUNNEL THERE AND STRAIGHTFORWARD
POLICY PROPOSALS THAT COULD
SOLVE FROM WHAT REGULATORS WANT
WHILE ALSO ALLOWING CRYPT BE TOE
CURRENCY TO REALLY GROW.
>> Jesse: MINI MADOFF HAD A
GRIFT OVER THE WHOLE SYSTEM.
REGULATORS IN HIS BACK POCKET
AND THE ONLY THING THAT GOT JOHN
FETTERMAN OF CRYPTO SHAKING IN
HIS BOOTS IS WHEN PEOPLE ASKED
HIM WHO EXACTLY WAS GETTING ALL
OF THIS MONEY?
>> DO WHAT'S RIGHT FOR THE
COUNTRY.
>> YOU THINK EVERY MONEY YOU
SPENT IN POLITICS SHOULD BE
DISCLOSED PUBLICLY ARE YOU
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT.
>> IF THERE WAS A NORM EVERY
DOLLAR DONATED IN POLITICS WAS
TOE BE DISCLOSED PUBLICLY, I
WOULD HAVE A LOT OF SYMPATHY FOR
THAT I THINK I MIGHT SUPPORT.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING IS MAYBE THERE IS SOME
DONATIONS THAT YOU HAD MAKE THAT
YOU WOULDN'T MAKE IF YOU KNEW
THEY WOULD BE IMMEDIATELY
PUBLIC.
>> SO I THINK -- I DON'T
GENERALLY THINK ABOUT IT THAT
WAY.
>> Jesse: WHY IS MINI MADOFF
SHAKING?
HE IS SHAKING.
NO ONE SHAKES WHEN THEY GET
INTERVIEWED BY CHUCK TODD.
CHUCK TODD IS NOT ASKING TOUGH
QUESTIONS.
HE KNOWS IS HE A SCAM ARTIST.
HE IS SHAKING.
AS LONG AS YOU NEVER GIVE UP THE
NAME, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
REGULATORS THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE YOUR BACK.
WE SAW IT IN 2008 WITH WALL
STREET.
WE SAW IT WITH ALL THESE MEGA
DONORS THAT DEMOCRATS TURNED A
BLIND EYE TO.
NOW WE ARE SEEING IT WITH A
CRYPTO FRAUDSTER, THE GUY WHO
JUST ROBBED A MILLION PEOP